no perché sto cercando di partire la
vedevo va bene per i ragazzi in questo
momento sono famiglie oggi siamo con
mark e marci
siamo davvero liberi michela milan sta
giustamente fissando da un ora
buongiorno mia amata cosa mi dici oggi
ben ritrovati ragazzi mi mancavate
soprattutto tutto fa vj sono proprio
contenta che tu sia riuscito a
sopravvivere agli ultimi scp forse se
riesci anche stavolta potrei uscire con
te è fatta ma non è ancora detto che
dobbiamo sopravvivere comunque ma non
pensiamoci adesso se non sarete
concentrati morirete atrocemente vi
trovate davanti all'hotel infestato dei
peggiori scp esistenti mio dio dovrete
usare tutte le risorse che avete per
uscirne vivi buona fortuna
ma alle gambe di che cosa di una
specifica angulo è un esercizio leggo
rigido che non va in palestra quindi
scappato lei va bene andiamo avanti ci
sono eccessivi le nostre teste la croce
è molto mike a quanta roba che gira
sempre tutto promessa secondo me che
parlo metodo ma c'è una cappa ma state
scherzando una cappellina ghana
mitraglieri state facendo sognare oggi
secondo me ci fa tutta questa roba
perché sarà tipo difficoltosissimo
uscire già la stoffa carta perché
sicuramente siamo molto sexy comunque
con questo vestito la casacca che lo
dico io sto bene a iolo bike o uscite
video camera ok ok non c'è niente per
adesso non c'è nulla di vero c'è notizia
non mi ricordo che se ci pietro ci sono
ragazzi alle 9 si sentiva aia dietro
ogni
ciò è vero ma scusa ai 1 mag e pieno è
pieno e pieno la ragazza è finita è
finita
vedo vedo tentacoli l'honda tumori ma
sono poi mi sto cagando sotto ma non
picchiati in 26 anni voglio stare sulle
testate aspetta che devono star li
picchia vaiano
chi è che mi chiama e mi picchia così
sono morti in un secondo c'erano
picchiati in 26 c'era il dottor come
rischiava al dottore di continua il
dottore plug the doctor slide doctor ne
sono i corni laica doctor esatto di
quello che devi continuare a fissare che
essi cpe scp 173 era il 173 ma mi
ricordo cosa quel tentacolo la
gigantesco scp 354 quello sc 354 in una
sua di preciso che numero però perché
tantissimi 300 adesso c'è anche una
mucca ci sono dei biscotti bello anche
eventuali errori
facciamo così visto dimmi mappa
impossibile avanti piano senza fare i
pirla che non casinò ragazzi in una
pietra armadio come è morto mi hai
ammazzato tool march ma dai ragazzi io i
nove lo vorrei dire ma qua c'è un cesso
che è stato strutturato da un ingegnere
un posto scusatemi cominciava la pago
contro contro il muro ok ma scusami il
secondo me è un sound effetto lo fai con
la bocca buona
i primi giri dg marco agosti pete va
bene la tv immagino che funzioni a
questo punto però poi scorreggiare
l'accesso bene lori guarda nell'armadio
io non ti consiglio di aprirlo è come si
apre un armadio così col tasto destro
dovrebbe essere stati allontanati non
funziona silvino qualsiasi cosa fosse ok
io ho fatto li ho fatti io far
tranquillo tranquillo sono sì sì sì si
guarda qua ok a posto l'unico modo ora
in varie misure ma si suona sarei di
sopra urlatrici ma ragazze ci sono i di
heaslip killer perché se c'è qualcuno
perché come si mettono che non c'e la
cosa per vedere dinho dobbiamo trovare
il visore sarà da qualche parte andiamo
a trovare di telepadania andiamo andiamo
volta liberato santa libera ho tratto un
piccone in garanzia posto come prendino
per il piccolo in diamante brasile si
può ancora come si chiamano di 163 c'è
una spada la sorprende la 2 la tela e
chi forse sì la telecamere è fortissimo
ma non è non è quella quella piccola
quella cross che sta picchiando un
romanzo gli onori faceva di avanti ti
sta picchiando un robot invisibile ma
come supporto e ti sarà picchia molto
più possibile
credo di averlo fatto fuori senza
guardare occhio siro con il nostro
uccidendo non l'avete folla uccidendo
l'ho ucciso senza vederlo più
incredibile è piena di killer o
chiocchio è morto perfetto bravo bravo
l'ha ucciso ti faccio fuori io ma quanti
sono
magari sono poveri
infermiera stavolta c'è la mega ragione
ci sono pazzi perché abbiamo se ci
abbiamo messo una videocamera isight
piller sono morti senza vederli pensate
come sia messi ma dove ricaricare l'ho
fatta
ma è così il killer ma quanti ce ne sono
dai primi ma basta ora è un'ora di slip
killer
ci sono degli esseri cicli molto senso
dei fenicotteri che si quelli sono pink
sono pink flamingos venite venite qua
ragazzi alla vista mi ha picchiato una
pecora è arrivato un vulnus culmine
esattorie vieni qua ciao ciao mi vedi
sto sparando in aria vicino a rieti dal
30 specie di se con un po di fenicotteri
ci siamo poi c'è un accesso intanto in
dipenderà certo arrivo carico di livello
4 piacevo livello 1 quindi perfetto
l'anello visore non avviso la assoluta
ma anche questo un altro tassa iniqua
marce oa pieroni di killer tanti allora
ragazzi facciamo così se volete tengo
sempre io sul visore è vero sui temi
forti della mappa quanta gente si sono
sempre tenuti dai ragazzi è pieno no no
no non beccarlo terzo amico perché è
perché sennò si scatenano tutti e alla
fine è proprio alla fine non vi chiamo
fans come faccio io ci penso io perché
ce l'avrai vedi ok si la vedo vedo
caserta un occhio ok occhio attenzione
guardato il picnic killer ok no niente
00 o ad odiarli ragazzi giovani che
prendono che c'è questo come si chiama
rifle il laser iphone
ok perfetto che bello arrivare
visto che avete già aperto uno permesso
risparmiare che va bene raga ma quant'è
brutto stesse cp qua ok prete sopra si
no sotto sotto che non devi
classificarmi di quelli che vedo così
rifaccia la cultura mattina occhio la
fecola che se ci dirà allora questa è la
whitman i boys sorella a la pecora nera
oggi e premi d'occhio
oggi paghiamo
nel bagno del piccolo ragazzi adesso
caduto risolto aiuto sono caduti dove a
posto fermo fermo fermo per contribuire
nel bagno vedo vedo
sto facendo fuori l'ho fatto fuori
l'avevo visto quello nel bagno
niente nomi è andato mi ha dato una
lingua latina in alto guarda in alto ci
sono delle armi prendiamo l'effetto sono
stravolti come se io sono pronto per
andare al bar o gambali gambali cambiano
qui qua c'è il 3 5 4 che è questo qui
che teoricamente ti amy agganciato
riagganciato cos'è la gancia toro di
agganciare di questo campo e come fai
per avvicinarti allora guarda cosa
facciamo
se mi faccio da diversivo in fa cup
italia e voli sparate ma che vai a marin
che punto il dottorando superandolo
ucciso vado a me era enorme le tele
killer delle vittime perché non è il
ricordo le brocche levavano tantissimo
può essere lisciotto non tutti tranne su
ip 096 ragazze a nonchè i equa di sopra
o calino scala c'è il tetto c'è un
sottotetto spettano attimo che vedere se
c'è qualcuno non c'è nessuno su tutte
sappiamo
no ragazzi ma cosa che c'è perché c'è un
accesso sull'albero e verona sono albero
come ci siano arrivati meglio la florens
mi sa che non ci arriva
c'è la carta di livello 5 era lì si
lamenta jonas perdita e io pur trovare
hoeness ma la chiama le l'havana iata
che la prova da aprile funziona via o
poi sono entrato con tre play press sul
play da allora dov'è in quello e mezzo
che ok dove ci ha portato ok dove siamo
in un laboratorio è una nuova di liberty
city c'è qualcuno dietro finestra ho
visto muoversi qualcosa ve lo giuro
e quando mi sembrano l'armata di una
bambina ecco la bambina mamma mia
ragazzi bile a dei ragazzi questo era il
primo episodio aree notare al terzo
bisogna esserci prima e continuo lo
faremo nel prossimo episodio visto che
sono trasportati in un'altra area
incredibile
questa è stata fuori ogni volta che
faccio una pari scp è sempre la più
difficile ma ogni volta aumenta la
difficoltà
io non so cosa dire però a ben vedremo
nel prossimo episodio cosa succede nel
frattempo lasciato un commento mi piace
se vi dove è piaciuto se non se la
preside iscrivetevi schiacciato anche la
campanella che trovato questo per
ricevere notifiche
vi lascio il canale anche di marsi e
marco sotto in descrizione e noi ci
diamo come sempre sta cercando scp
telecomando precederà il video beh
ragazzi
[Musica]